there seems to be an epidemic on on on
Tick Tock of people trying to expose
creepy men at the gym now considering
the fact that the woman from the
previous video we covered uh ended up
apologizing and wrote this long apology
on Twitter saying you know I shouldn't
have done this and honestly I realized
now that I was wrong and I
misinterpreted and I use my truck you
know whatever I'm gonna play some video
for you guys and I want you guys to see
a difference between something that is
reprehensive over something that's not
okay surreal watch this guy try move to
me at the gym
Jack's absolutely nothing on his phone
over at me being busy sorting my wrist
straps
these [__] straps taking up too much
time
mix a swift return
sad lip
so I want to share my perspective on
this video the showman walks up he's
looking for a machine to use and he asks
you are you using the machine behind you
why does he do this well maybe some of
your stuff is close to that machine you
know we carry these big bags these water
jugs these belts all this stuff maybe
some of it is close to the machine and
he just wants to be kind and polite also
looks like he might be new to the gym he
looks lost confused he looks like he
might be a little bit intimidated it's
even to the point where you make fun of
him for not knowing the name of the
machine
and let me ask you this if he were to
jump on a machine that you were using
and he didn't ask you and you caught
that on film would you post that to make
fun of him
something to think about you know it's
really sad that you took this
interaction you had to post it you had
to shame this man to make him ought to
be a gym creep that he's trying to hit
on you just for attention and likes the
gym is a shared space people are going
to interact with you this is harmless
this man asks you a question you say no
and he moves on this video Never needs
to be posted
you need to do better
mind your own business
I mean Joey said everything Joey said
what he said there's a whole Trend right
now if women want to be like I curved
him this guy's creepy I caught it on
camera ladies support me recognizing a
lot of his behavior is innocuous
you were ascribing to him intentions
that he may not have oh he looked at his
phone checking out nothing how do you
know
and let's say he was maybe he's doing it
because like the guy said he's new to
the gym he doesn't actually know how to
act so he looks at his phone because
he's like damn my workout's not going
well I look small people have deep
insecurities when they're in public they
look at their phone sometimes for a
sense of comfort it's not about you
maybe he sees the camera that you put up
recording a bunch of people at the gym
and he's feeling self-conscious on
himself so he's like I'll pull out my
phone so I don't look stupid there's a
plethora of reasons why people that but
you inherently go to creepy and then
blast him online
you know what
let's say he was interested
what did he do
let's say he was looking at nothing at
his phone and he was actually interested
what did he do I got another one for you
put your head down
okay now get naked
so everybody gonna put these two hands
out just in front of them
don't worry don't worry all right now
you guys can open your eyes
[Music]
[Applause]
but the one that's left
that looks like mine the only reason
I personally love this wallet I've got
my own right here and watch is great
it's minimalistic uh it carries
everything they look stylish
um and they come at really amazing
prices and I want you guys to be able to
do the same whether it's getting one for
yourself or one for a significant other
because Valentine's Day is coming up if
you use the link in the description
below you get 35 off for this
Valentine's Day Sale get yourself an
extra like this poop so this video I
think is a bit different let's watch it
I was just trying to work out when this
happens
[Music]
foreign
I've never met this guy and he's been
harassing me for months
friends they changed
they changed the personality
this time I kept my headphones in and
tried to ignore him
[Music]
something you're gonna ask why is she
filming yourself well she's probably
feeling herself to for the form
yeah because you have no way of
looking and watching if your form is
nice right uh yeah that was creepy
that that was
undeniably yo if you like hey yo did you
listen what he said he said my
girlfriend you know they changed her
personality he's doing some kind of
schizo like some some kind of weird
brand talking about like and then he
walks away then he circles back pointing
at her yeah and then he gets within her
ear there is no scenario where you tell
me something like that's appropriate no
right and so if you share something like
that I'm like yeah that's unacceptable
turns out they located this dude on the
security Fleet and they ended up Banning
him at the gym that's fine right the
general public the people who are
reasonable can look at that situation be
like that's inappropriate okay
but this situation is similar to uh
racism right in this sense
if I encounter scenario when everything
is undercover and you know a lot of it
is subliminal
if I try to call it out
there's no evidence there's no evidence
they're going to call the dog right I
could be like in his head like the
reason why you looked at me that way is
because of this but then I end up
looking crazy it could be also that I'm
just wrong and I don't know what I'm
talking about and believe it or not some
of you all wrong some of you guys go to
the [__] store don't have enough
money want to leave with the product the
person says no and you'll be like that's
because what some people weaponize it
some people misinterpret situations and
make it about race and other times it's
subliminal you actually have no evidence
right and there's times where you get it
right on camera and there's people in
the public who will deny and deny that
it's that and those people you can never
win them right they're so they want to
believe there's nothing racist in the
world there's unreasonable people I'm
not one of those people not when it
comes to this issue right I believe that
there's men who go after women I believe
there's men who invade their spaces in
their gym and do some inappropriate
stuff but I also believe that there's
women who are weaponizing a lot of this
[__] to go after men unjustly
and that's not okay the same way what he
did to that girl when he went that's not
okay
I work with preach and I never get that
close to his ear well you did three
times now what
what do you mean you just did three
times out three times I did this yeah
okay but replicating what he does
you've done that too replicate not what
he did but you'd be like
yay
yeah I do that sometimes that's okay you
guys get the [__] point done okay
all right like yeah
this was a whole nothing yeah
listen I like AirPlay too not from
strangers
that's not weird like we all like ear
play who doesn't like their ear nibbled
on there oh
[__]
okay we all like it we all enjoy most of
us some of y'all don't
and those people
vanilla's [__] so in the end with this
guy I think we can start to tell the
difference we just have to be careful
not to ascribe people intentions without
actually knowing that's a bunch of
people like on the web and on Instagram
posting recently there was a guy talking
about cops or the cops this cops that
were abusive uh his guy stopped me the
guy this guy was doing was all doing he
was over the limit yeah I'm being
harassed because the cops no no no
actually you were going over the limit
that's not what we're talking about okay
shut up keep move on that's not what it
is that's not harassment that's you
going over the speed limit shut up
true so yeah at the end that's how I
feel about this stuff
um I don't like this trend I don't like
that people are weaponizing this stuff
and the whole word okay this is
something that actually pays me I hate
the word creepy I hate the word creepy I
hate the way people misuse it I hate the
way people weaponize it and I hate the
way that women Escape accountability for
using it against men unjustly was also
whilst also pretending like they didn't
mean anything by it
sorry you can't just casually call
everything you don't like creepy
a dude who's ugly comes up to you and
says hello you're like oh you're so
creepy no a handsome man comes up he's
like oh so dreamy
what's the difference the problem is not
the behavior the problem is not the
behavior a lot of the times some y'all
just don't like who's doing it yeah oh
he's looking at me that's funny that
creepy why why oh his energy what
because he lacks confidence he's a creep
is that what that is
go ahead he lacks confidence you don't
like his demeanor so he's creepy uh
handsome man is in the same [__] club
looking at you and now you make an eye
contact and the behavior is acceptable
what the [__] is the difference how is a
man supposed to know
but it's creepy
I just want to recognize how unfair that
is because there's a serious connotation
when you say a man is creepy there's
something sexually any like
inappropriate about him that's what they
even see you sexual it's like
it's borderline it's borderline criminal
when nothing creepy yes is whenever you
see creepy we're talking about horror
movies we're talking about uh stalkerish
we talking about that's what you say
when you say creepy you understand what
I'm saying yeah and it's just funny that
in 2015 uh uh 50 Shades of Gray was one
of the best sellers and fast forward
2017 everything is abuse and everything
is creepy true yeah if Christian Gray
was another man and not rich it would
have been creepy all right
um
those are my notes that's all I really
had anything else
let us know what you guys think in the
comments below we want to hear from you